ふぇ
ふう
こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
2日間動画出せませんでした。
お久しぶりです。はじめしゃちょー です
言い訳 てかもう シンプルなことなんですけども
東京に3日間いましてその3日間がもうほとんど
朝から 夜まで いろんな お仕事 とか 撮影 とか イベント とか 色んな事やってて
あの 全く 動画 を 撮る タイミング
場所 いろんな 要素 で もう 動画 が 撮れなくて 二日間 休んでしまいました
大変申し訳ございません でした とは 言わないんです      けど なぜなら 私 は 毎日投稿 します とは
一言も言ったことはない 謝ること じゃないんです けど個人的には なるべく
動画だしたいなと 思ってて 正直 2日 連続休んだのが      ちょっと あの 僕の中 で すごい
悔しいです！ と言う 悔しい なんか 東京 で 3日間          居たんですけども 今日で
ケリをつけよう と 思います もう前から
ずっと 言ってるわけですよ 静岡に 住んでるから
東京行くと 動画 が 撮れなくなる
うーん
東京に引っ越そうかな  でも 静岡 いいなぁって こう 色々 言ってたんですけど 結局 僕はまだ 静岡
に 留まってる から 今回みたいな こと が
起きてしまった 心のどこかで
本末転倒 している 気が して やっぱり
メイン の動画 を 出して 初めて 僕
YouTuber の仕事やってます って言うんで そこが         疎かになる と やっぱ 僕何かなぁ
これ違うんだろうなって 思ってたり かと いって
東京 行かないわけ にも いきませんし
そして 僕には もう 仲間がいます 畑と いうための 仲間も居るから結局 で 拠点 がどこになる
かっていう のが すごい
今 ますます 大事になってます 何ならもう 畑でも         東京 行くこと が あります からね 実はあのー、
今週も 3 回 3 日間 東京 行ってるんです けど 更に         週末 に もう1回 畑で 東京 行くん
で 週 4 回 東京   1週間の半分以上 東京 に いるわけで   ございます 正直に言わせていただきます
このままだと 動画 が 撮れません 結構   あの そろそろ マジで やばいな と思って けど やっぱり僕は
静岡が大好きです できる限り 静岡にいたい と いう     想いも 相当 強いし なん か 東京 に行くと
東京に 染まりそうで 僕は心配です はじめしゃちょー  です どうすればいいですか
静岡に 居たい でも 東京 にいた方 が 動画が出せる       もう 何なら
なんか 愛知 とか 行っちゃっても いい んじゃない        みたいな え 北海道  沖縄 ありだな 色んな
いや ないわ それは 東京 に 行くべきか
静岡に残るべきかすごい
僕 正直 あの イーブン なんですよね 静岡
でも無理すれば 動画 出せる し
東京だったら なんか 時間も できる し
畑全員で 移動すれば すごい時間も確保 できる             さぁ どっちを取る！！
って言われたとき に あの 僕1人じゃ
決めかねない と 思うんですよ という わけで
今日の動画 は 皆さんに！
私 はじめしゃちょー が どこで 生活すれ ば いいかを   決めて いただきたいと思います 宜しく お願いします
ちなみに 畑も全員ついてきます あの ちゃんと
畑に入る前に 皆さんには言ってあるんですよ
ひょっとしたら 静岡じゃない場所 に 移動するかも      知れません その覚悟がある上 で 畑に入りませんか？
って感じで聞いてるんでみんな 絶対 ついてくるので    安心してください
僕は本当にイーブンです あの 東京  静岡
もう どっち で も いい  ただ 東京となると
物件、動画ちゃんと 撮れる 物件 探す のが 大変だと    思ってるんで  いや でも 静岡にも居たい
大家さんがすごい優しい という訳であの
この動画のコメント欄で 東京に行くか 静岡に残るか   決めていただきたい と思います  2 月中に
僕 コメント欄に  2個書いておきます 静岡と
東京って書いとくんで どっちかに  goodボタンを押してください 2月が終わった時点で多い方に行きます
そこに 住みます よろしくお願いします ただ ねぇ うん
もうそろそろちゃんと決めるべきだと思う 腹を括って
迷っているようじゃダメだ なんかもう
モヤモヤするんですよね
なんとかなるんじゃねえかという思いと こういうことだって 割り切って 動画 休むっていうのは はっきり  決めたいんで こういう時はもうコイントスで
決めようかみたいな感じで 皆さんに
お聞きいたします あの
本当に迷っています 皆さん 皆さん投票の方
2月いっぱい コメント欄でお待ちしておりますので goodボタン よろしくお願い致します
１回 畑にも 聞いてみますか
思いついたぞ
ポジ うーん
皆さん お知らせです
東京に 引越します！
というアンケートを取ります
あー なるほど なるほど
それを決めるのは コメント欄のgood数で
決めようかなぁって
コメント欄のgood数で？
あー何が、東京か静岡かっ
てコメントを2つ用意してgood数で… そうそう
そういう事そんなに急いで行く訳じゃないよ
ゆくゆく
どっちかにしろ 静岡に残るにしろ 東京に行くにしろ
うんっ、まぁ多分 俺らだけだったら
どっちが良いっすかね？って決まんなかったと思うし
俺たちだと決めきれないんで、
かといってコイントスも恐いんで
見てる皆さんの意見に沿ってはいいんじゃないかと
けど ほぼ コイントスですよね   実質ね？